et je poursuis avec michael kraus
professeur émérite de droit universel du
range mason en virginie et timothy la
photo historien professeur à
l'université de new york
bonsoir à vous deux pourquoi alors
d'abord j'aimerais avoir votre réaction
à ce que vous avez vu aujourd'hui les
images tellement troublante quand même
commençons avec vous monsieur crasse
dans la chambre des représentants l'une
des choses les plus déchirantes que j'ai
jamais vu surtout depuis disons le 11
septembre 2001 la chose la plus
déchirante du gaz lacrymogènes utilisés
à l'extérieur des salles de la chambre
c'est une honte nationale
je peux pas exprimer il n'y a pas de
mots suffisamment déprimant pour
exprimer mes sentiments
ouais mais c'est naftal et ils s'en sont
pris aux symboles grand symbole de la
démocratie américaine et avec tellement
de facilité comment vous avez réagi
c'était avec caen de tristesse que j'ai
vu nu les événements d'aujourd'hui
j'étais étonné complètement étonné que
que le capitaine était mieux protégés on
savait bien que aujourd'hui il y aura
une manifestation il peut être une
limite à cause du fait que le président
à m il a il était celui qui il n'a pas
organisé la manifestation d'aujourd'hui
mais il a poussé il a encouragé
six militants d'aller à washington
aujourd'hui alors j'étais vraiment
surpris qu'il n'y avait pas à des idées
préparation à pour protéger le capital
iq et fils il prenait à peu près deux ou
trois heures pour qu'il y aura assez
policiers et de militaires nous protéger
a les représentants alors c'était
étonnant
c'était déchirant aucun maladie et c'est
vraiment vraiment ri oui et vous
monsieur crasse pour vous quelle est la
responsabilité de donald thompson attali
faisait allusion est-ce qu'il n'a pas
mis de lui
ils sont le feu aujourd'hui encore en
disant qu'ils ne considéraient jamais la
victoire à dubaï dun il a fait plus
qu'ali mais la mèche comme le dit
monsieur jean tonnes il a fourni le mesh
c'est lui qui a tout fait il a provoqué
c'est lui qui a demandé aux manifestants
de marcher vers le capitole
cette vie qui a avec des mots à peine
cachée demander à ces gens là de le
rétablir comme président il me dorothée
capturer un peu le capitole qui selon
lui a été volé par ses adversaires il
il a déchaîné il a fomenté une
insurrection qui est en violation
directe de son serment d'office c'est
pourquoi à mon avis il doit être
maintenant destitué même s'il ne lui
reste que 14 jours dans son mandat se
prendre deux jours pour le destituer la
chambre des représentants et de
condamner au sénat et il le mérite il
faut le faire mais c'est nafta nickel à
venir selon vous que monsieur janka qui
reste encore quatorze jours là encore au
pouvoir
ils doivent être condamnées et j'attends
aujourd'hui j'observe les propos des
membres républicains de la chambre pour
voir s'il y a un désir premier parmi eux
de pousser le président de faire
démissionner ou de tâches et des
institutions comme dit mike ross healy a
assez de temps pour une destitution et
un procès mais faut la participation des
républicains et jean je ne suis pas sûr
maintenant qu'ils sont prêts à prendre
ce à prendre cette décision et à l'autre
bannière de pousser le président essaie
d utiliser l'article oulémas des
modifications 25 kim et ça prend la
participation du vice président ils
doivent prendre la décision que le
président n'est pas capable de
poursuivre ses responsabilités mais on
ne sait pas si le vice président lui
même est préféré à faire ça alors je
pense
ce que nous avons vécu nous allons vivre
de très difficile semaine avant que
monsieur tron par et à quel point
êtes-vous surpris michael kraus parce
que vous nous aviez dit en septembre que
rien n'indiquait qu'il n'allait pas
reconnaître une éventuelle défaite et là
on voit aussi ce qui est en train de se
passer
oui je dois dire que je le croyais et je
pense que la plupart des gens le
croyaient malade en ce sens qu'il était
il est évident qu'il était nertiti qu
c'était c'est une malaise qui affiche
beaucoup de politiciens peut-être mais
monsieur trombe sur tout mais maintenant
il est plus que malade je pense qu'il
est cinglé disons il il refuse
d'accepter la défaite je croyais je
passe quatre mais je crois qu'ils
croient vraiment que l'élection était
volé il est tellement il est totalement
incapable et je croyais pas tellement
malade je savais narcissique mais depuis
les élections il n'a rien fait par 30 et
de délégitimer le résultat c'est inouï
et vous savez si le destituer la
destitution selon la constitution
américaine fait deux choses il n'est
plus président et qui ne plus jamais il
ne peut jamais plus se porter candidat à
un poste fédérant tous ceux qui
craignent ils réapparaissent en 2024 se
débarrasser de lui avec destitution et
est-ce que ça est ce qu'on peut et
est-ce qu'on peut s'inquiéter par contre
une institution ou d'un processus qui
sera enclenchée après ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui est ce que ça pourrait
susciter plus que ça monsieur nafali oui
un des jets peur j'étais inquiète que pc
pas seulement une question de
d'enlèvement d'enfants il a poussé un
mouvement il n'a pas créé ce mouvement
on avait des extrémistes du droit de la
droite avant dans l'autre mais ce qu'il
a fait
il est légitime ou illégitime et team et
sept mouvements et il a grandi ce moment
et je ne crois pas que ce mouvement va
disparaître hommes afin que qu'il parle
de la maison blanche alors les chefs le
publicain les gens avec des fluence à
sur la droite
ils ont maintenant grâce potabilité
national de parler aux gens qui font
qu'ils sauce qui sont partis qui sont
autour d'eux tran qu'ils appuient 3 elle
leur dit que l'élection il termine et
que c'est fini qu'ils ont perdus qu'ils
aura une autre chance dans quatre ans il
faut avoir du leadership de s'est pas
seulement une question dans les vitraux
parce que le tropisme peuvent continuer
130 me se crashe il est quand même assez
isolé maintenant monsieur une chambre
alors qui peut lui dire qui doit lui
dire sa femme peut-être celui d'hier
peut être sa fille peut-être son genre
peut lui dire vous savez j'ai un bon ami
à moi qui qui est haut placés dans le
parti républicain
il a écrit le tweet soudain il y à peu
près d'une heure sur twitter il a écrit
je ne suis pas un démocrate je n'ai
jamais voté pour un démocrate toute ma
vie autant je veux l'inculpé je venais
destitué je vais l'exclure de tout à
fait seul avenir
il y à des millions et des millions de
républicaine j'aurais pu écrire ces mots
moi même
il a dit il ya des millions de gens qui
maintenant se sont dit il a vieilli il a
passé une ligne il a il a traversé la
première actes répréhensibles il a
commis un acte criminel
il n'est plus là il n'est plus apte à
exercer le poste président mais que
peut-il père vous savez il veut revenus
est ce qui va devenir en floride somme
de thil que chez lui à palm beach en
floride
ses voisins ne veulent plus la voir
comme boisé il n'a y là on lui a refusé
un visa pour aller en écosse
pour lever janvier il voulait être en
écosse de les construire plus
identifiées alors c'est un problème plus
pair avec le sucre rhum après ces quatre
années vraiment tumultueuse alors
michael kraus timothy naftali merci
beaucoup à vous deux c'est important
nous entendre ce soir c'est rosselli
merci